[Music]
[Applause]
to bring in Mike Mike Florio pro
football talk live co-host NBC football
night America contributor and the show
The pre-seize Hours on peacock
uh let's start with Lamar Jackson here
how did we get to this point and we
always love to say what's the true value
of the contract and who won and who lost
here
well we don't know the True Value yet
because we haven't seen the full numbers
we have limited information so far but
it's a five-year 260 million dollar
contract from signing usually it's an
extension and we ignore the fact that
there's old money involved let me give
you a great example good comparison
Jalen hurts
he actually has a six-year 259 million
dollar contract when it's signed and
when it's applied the mar 5 years 260
Lamar makes more over five years than
Jalen hurts makes over six years because
Jalen hurts had that one year left that
gets attached to the five-year extension
making it a six-year contract so there's
little things like that that need to be
explained it's easier though once we get
the full numbers and we'll get the full
numbers Dan full guarantee it's signing
and also how much of the injury
guarantee becomes fully guaranteed after
the first year because they're not going
to cut them after one year how much
flips what's that total number that
helps us understand how good of a deal
it is
any chance the Ravens regret this
or will I don't think they regret it I
think they regret the fact that they
couldn't have gotten it done sooner okay
I think it should have been done last
August look we reported in the aftermath
of the Jalen hurts deal and I think the
Jalen hurts deal Dan
was a very valuable piece of this I
think it snapped Lamar Jackson out of
his DeShaun Watson fever dream it
finally got him to realize I'm not
getting five years fully guaranteed 230
240 250 million it's not happening it's
the aberration it's the outlier I have
to do a traditional deal like Jalen
hurts and that's what he did now I think
he should have done it last August last
August he would have gotten 133 million
fully guaranteed at signing last August
he would have signed a deal that would
have flipped another 35 million to fully
guaranteed in March of this year for 168
that would have been fully guaranteed as
a practical matter he should have done
it in August and I'm going to be very
interested to compare
the key factors from this deal to what I
know about the deal he rejected in
August but he finally woke up and
realized this is the key because if
you're like oh he he won or he didn't
need an agent after all or whatever he
needed someone to wake him up whether it
was Odell Beckham Jr whether it was
Jalen hurts contract something woke him
up to get him to realize I'm not going
to get what I want I better just take
what I can get
what's Aaron Rodgers getting paid this
year
60 million okay where did I see 107
million
there's all sorts of different numbers
that flow around look his cash flow is
100 oh yeah they did something with his
contract yeah
and I don't I haven't seen the actual
documents yet so I'm not ready to accept
that someone else's characterization of
it is accurate there was something about
his salary next year being 107 million
but that's including the 60 million he's
due to make this year but he's still
going to make 60 million this year he's
not playing for a million bucks this
year in New York they did something in
Green Bay so they could trade the
contract in a way that reduced the cap
hit but the Jets aren't paying him any
less this year than what he was supposed
to make he didn't take a pay cut but
they're not paying him 107 million
dollars this year no 60 million okay is
what he was due to make this year and
I've heard nothing to suggest he's taken
a penny less than 60 million but that's
still pretty good for a guy who's
pushing 40. 60 million dollars in cash
flow this year under the contract he
signed last year with the Packers and
and I don't want to front load this
because I want to entice you to play
next year and there's no guarantee and
what did you make of what happened with
the Jets in the draft with the a team
that needed offensive line and they
ended up getting somebody for the
defense hidden cost of that final Aaron
Rodgers trade look Dan I think the Jets
got fleeced here
when you look at everything they gave up
they were desperate to get this guy the
the pick next year the second round of
it becomes a first rounder
all it takes is Aaron Rodgers playing
just over 11 games this year and the
second round becomes a first rounder
they don't have to make the playoffs for
it to become a first round but they
don't have to win a playoff game they'll
have to win a single regular season game
that could be a top five pick let's say
he gets injured and misses five games
and they struggle they got a tough
schedule they failed to make the
playoffs they're in the top ten Packers
get that pick if he plays 65 percent of
the snaps and then the kicker was the
flip-flop 13 to 15. you fall to 15. what
happens Steelers cut the line they take
the tackle that you may have wanted and
you have to go other side of the line
that's the hidden cost of this deal but
they were desperate to get it done my
theory is Woody Johnson the owner of the
Jets said to somebody on Monday get this
bleepity bleep thing done today I'm sick
of this hanging over our heads
I'm watching the body language of the
Cowboys in the war room
and I think they got surprised by the
Buffalo Bills what do you make of what
the Cowboys did that they you know you
have to you're on camera you got to be
excited for the cameras do you think the
Cowboys got the player that they truly
wanted Mike
well look they're never going to admit
it they're always going to say they got
the guy they would have taken even if we
had the first overall pick in the draft
but that moved by the bills I Sims and I
were talking about this earlier today
you know the bills need Playmakers on
offense all they have is Stefan Diggs
especially at receiver and Dawson Knox
look he's no slouch but they need they
need a receiver you get through 19 picks
and not every single receiver he's taken
this is great for the bells and then
receiver receiver receiver receiver and
you know the Cowboys are lurking for a
potential tight end and I thought the
bills were going to move up even higher
than they did but I think they got
desperate to get that guy and now they
have Dawson Knox and Dalton Kincaid
how's that going to work out I don't
know but they need pass catchers for
Josh alley he's Mike Florio from pro
football talk live let's play the will
Levis game who takes him
well
you know you got teams out there that
were potentially looking at quarterback
that didn't take one in round one what
happens in round two does Tennessee try
to move up do the Steelers dangle that
pick all day long to whoever wants will
love us somebody explained to me I
haven't written this yet but somebody
explained to these me this morning what
can happen when a slide begins there are
so many insecure teams about their own
evaluation that when a guy starts to
slide they doubt their evaluation and
they worry what are others going to say
what's the owner going to say what if he
doesn't work out you have your
evaluation and the person I talked to
today thinks 20 to 25 teams had a first
round grade on will lettuce but once he
starts to go people get wobbly about
what they really think and that slide
gets fueled so that raises the
possibility one of these teams out there
Dan that is thinking we need a
quarterback we didn't get one last night
let's see if we can trade up and get in
position to get will Levis and it's good
for Levis from this standpoint it's a
four-year contract not five years it's
better to go high round two than low
round one because you don't have to
worry about the fifth year option like
Dak Prescott even though he went far
later than round one he was able to put
the Cowboys in the corner pretty quickly
I don't know if that made him feel good
last night at 11 o'clock as he's trying
to slink out of the Green Room Dan
somebody did not properly set his
expectations that's the most important
thing the agent can do you got to
prepare your client for your worst case
scenario where is your floor well Mike
nobody told him his floor is all the way
out around one I want to play this from
his Pro Day Marvin play uh will Levis
if I get invited and like if I know like
I'll be a pretty high pick I'll
definitely go I'm looking forward to
going but um
I don't want to go if like I could be
like a second round pick you know you
want to be that you don't want to have
the camera just on you
well
it's exactly exactly we have a new agent
hey Geno Smith remember when he fell out
around one yeah and he he didn't come
back at first on day two and then he
gets pick he changed agents not long
after that somebody failed to prepare
him for what was going to happen or he
wouldn't have gone why go why put
yourself through that if you think
there's a chance you're gonna slide all
the way out around one does he go today
I think he goes today I don't think it's
going to continue I think no does he
show up today
good question good question uh I
wouldn't I know I wouldn't have gone
unless I'm damn sure I'm one of the top
five guys I wouldn't have even gone so I
think that's going to be a real tough
one to get him to go back but but
hasn't the commissioner said before
didn't they say hey stop putting a
camera on
some of these guys who start falling hey
it's good TV but you know at some point
you're like come on you know what cut
the kid a break Dan it's on my list of
things to track down I feel like at some
point over the past 15 years I wrote a
story about that now I just have to go
find it you know it moves pretty quickly
in these parts but I'm pretty sure my
adult brain vaguely recalls something
like that where they wanted to to make
it less taxing on the player more Humane
more positive less Negative they don't
want that dramatic moment where we're
all
enjoying in a weird sort of way this
stress and strain so we saw a few shots
last night and it was clear that will
Levis was not prepared for what
ultimately happened where does Hendon
hooker go
well I mean he's a prime candidate for
the Titans because you don't need him
this year torn ACL
not going to be ready this year don't
rush him into The Fray this year there's
a thought maybe hooker actually goes
higher than Levis if people are really
freaked out is the Malik Willis era over
before it even started in Tennessee I
think the moment they benched him for
Josh Dobbs last year is when it ended
okay I mean think about it the they're
in the playoff push
and
I remember that 30 that game was
approaching against the Cowboys it's
like they're they're what they're
starting Josh Dobbs instead of Malik
Willis what are they doing they're
saving Malik Willis for the playoffs
they just assume they're making the
postseason it makes no sense to me but
think about the disconnect that
apparently was there between John
Robinson the former GM and Mike virable
the head coach remember last year the
scene when they trade AJ Brown and Rabel
looks like he's ready to throw someone
through a wall I I that may have been a
pick where Robinson thinks Malik Willis
is the guy and varable was never really
sold on it and so now we move on from
Malik Willis the best pick last night
was made by who
bad
I I really was fascinated by Bijon
Robinson and I think the Falcons went
from Fringe team of relevance to real
contender in one Fell Swoop they do love
to run the ball Mike you know over 50
percent they're one of three teams that
they run the ball more than they pass
they were seven and ten each of the last
two years and it doesn't seem that they
were that good yeah they're in a wide
open division in a conference where all
the great talent keeps leaving for the
AFC yes the Eagles are really good yes
the 49ers are really good but when you
look at the skill position players they
have now Kyle Pitts and Drake London and
Tyler algier who still has a role in
that team and I forgot about Cordell
Patterson people like oh well Desmond
Ritter he's not a good quarterback well
I could be a good quarterback with that
many great players around God forbid all
you gotta do is hand the football off
and off they go so Arthur Smith a great
offensive mind I I think now with Bijon
Robinson the Falcons are the team I'd
pick to win that
and Algeria ran for what 1100 years yeah
I know and they got him out of nowhere
uh it's Joe Burrows contract bigger than
Lamar Jackson yes is Justin Herbert's
bigger than Lamar Jackson's
yes maybe by a little bit if I'm Herbert
I want to see what burrow gets and then
I want to try to come in between burrow
and and Lamar Jackson oh so you don't if
you're Herbert you don't go now no I
want to see what burrow gets if I'm
Herbert okay
I think burrow is the one guy who may
come out of this Dan with like a 10-year
contract and his compensation is tied to
a percentage of the salary cap players
have tried to get that teams have said
no I think Mike Brown the owner of the
Bengals is enough of a renegade to tell
the league I don't care this makes sense
for us we're going to give Joe borrow a
set percentage so as the cap goes up his
pay goes up the contract is never
obsolete look at the Patrick Mahomes
deal in light of all these other
contracts I know what Petro homes
getting robbed right now yeah and the
Chiefs are lucky that he's he's wired in
a way that he's not kicking in someone's
door saying take care of my contract but
they need to take care of his contract I
think the Bengals avoid that if they
give Joe burrow a percentage of the cap
have a good weekend Mike thanks for
joining us thanks Nancy about Mike
Florio pro football talk live
yeah we said it at the time with Mahomes
that is a Team friendly deal